donner la parole à la société civile
plutôt qu'aux chefs d'état c'est
l'objectif du nouveau sommet afrique
france qui sera inaugurée aujourd'hui
par emmanuel macron quelques 3000
participants sont à montpellier des
rencontres les tables rondes entre
société civile africaine française et de
la diaspora sur des sujets économiques
culturelles et politiques le chef de
l'état souhaite rénover les relations
avec l'afrique en débloquant par exemple
un fonds d'innovation pour la démocratie
de 30 millions d'euros afin de soutenir
la société civile ont fait le point avec
notre envoyé spécial à montpellier
samantha ronson
comme prévu pas surprise nous avons été
refoulé à l'entrée presse du sommet
malgré notre inscription sur le site
média du nouveau sommet afrique france
il ya plusieurs semaines aux
accréditations n'ont pas été acceptées
l'agent en charge à des médias nous a
indiqué le motif suivant pas
d'accréditation pour des raisons de
sécurité sur décision de la préfecture
le nouveau sommet afrique france qui a
débuté il ya quelques heures maintenant
mais on a observé quelques cafouillages
il est 11 heures passées et vous le
voyez derrière moi il ya beaucoup
d'invités de délégations en attente de
pouvoir entrer à l'intérieur du site
pour l'occasion un dispositif de
sécurité important emmanuel macron est
attendu pour dialoguer
s'exprimer devant la jeunesse et la
société civile et ils sont nombreux je
vous le disais donc à patienter et
compris même des journalistes comme
lassana camara journaliste de l'agencé
de presse press africaine france bonjour
la fana merci de nous répondre ça fait
longtemps que vous attendez ça fait plus
d'une heure de temps qu'on attend pour
rentrer il ya beaucoup de filtrage ya
beaucoup de sécurité mais nous notre
attente peut être atténuée on est
indignée par ce qu'on a appris que toute
la presse n'est pas ne sera pas à
consulter la presse russe votre média la
rt france qui relaye les informations
depuis la france n'est pas son
accréditation c'est pas normal c'est pas
normal qu'on qu'on ne donne pas la
parole à toute la pression on veut que
les relations entre la france et
l'afrique soit puni par par tous soient
distribués partout soit relayé par tous
il faut que toute la presse mondiale
soit au courant de l'événement soit au
courant de l'évolution si on
essaye de tout simplement divisé la
presse ça vous dit qu'il ya quelque
chose qu'on cache emmanuel macron doit
s'exprimer aux côtés d'achille d'inde et
qui lui a rendu un rapport de 140 pages
avec treize propositions dans la lignée
des récents rapports qui ont été remis
au président notamment le rapport sur la
restitution des objets d'art africain et
celui sur l'algérie de benjamin stora
qu'attendez-vous précisément de ce
nouveau format où les chefs d'état
finalement non pas à ne sont pas conviés
on n'attend pas grand-chose parce que
depuis le discours de ouagadougou on n'a
rien vu venir de nouveaux on a plutôt vu
de soutien de coup d'état de soutien à
géométrie variable ce que la seule chose
qu'on peut attendre de positif enfin
toute la diaspora africaine 3000 invités
seront là il y aura des rencontres y
aura deux essence peut être entre les
africains il y aura une nouvelle page
qui vote qui va s'écrire je pense que le
président le maquereau va parler je
pense qu'il doit écouter peut-être y
aura des questions pertinentes par
rapport à cette relation entre la france
et l'afrique sont plus des relations
pour l'instant je pense que c'est une
domination la colonisation continue et
les spirituels et les intellectuels
parce qu'on ne peut plus comprendre que
40 ans après les indépendances de 40 ans
après les indépendances là les banques
africaines les pays qui ont le cfaa
n'ont toujours pas de banque centrale
c'est la france qui dirige tout qui
drive tout c'est pas c'est pas normal
espérons espérons qu'il ya un nouveau
vent va souffler après ce discours c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu des précédents sommets
afrique france depuis le discours de la
baule de françois mitterrand sur fond
d'effondrement de l'union soviétique à
celui que vous avez cités tout récemment
d' emmanuel macron devant la jeunesse
burkinabè à ouagadougou finalement c'est
le même refrain qui revient il faut
changer de paradigme pour refonder la
relation afrique-france sur une base
d'égal à égal mais ce que l'on voit
c'est qu'on piétine n'y a rien qui
change vraiment comment l'expliquer on
ne comprend pas parce que quand macro
est vite devenu président après le
discours de ouagadougou il avait
constitué une structure s'appelle cpa
conseiller présidentiel pour l'afrique
il y avait des écrivains des
entrepreneurs des artistes des
intellectuels qui était dans cette
théorie cela il remonte désinformation
presse dans la république mais les
informations du moment tu peux faire des
rapports peut-être des tonnes de la
porte quand les rapports ne sont pas lus
katia pas suivies d'effet rien ne va se
passer le problème on ne va pas tout
simplement incriminé seulement la france
on va incriminé l'afrique une telle
audience et a fait qu'il loupe le pauvre
les pouvoirs publics africains nos
dirigeants africains qui nourrit ont
compris qu'ils n'ont pas d'ambition pour
l'afrique qui sont là pour remplir les
poches et est parti c'est ça qui est
malheureux espérons que des lendemains
qui chantent pour la jeunesse africaine
je pense que maintenant avec beaucoup de
jeunes africains qui sont diplômés qui
ont parcouru le moins qui sont pas
seulement en france qu'ils soient
réussies qui sont à notre avis pour
changer beaucoup beaucoup de sociétés en
russie pendant la coupe du monde 2018 en
russie une magnifique combinant la plus
l'accotement de la plus organisée j'ai
vu beaucoup d'intellectuels à
l'université patrice lumumba qui
commence à réfléchir à l'afrique qui
commence à réfléchir au lendemain de
l'afrique je pense qu'il ne faut pas
plus simplement s'arrêter à des
relations franco africaines il faut tout
simplement réfléchir à une relation avec
moult faux constats on s'intéresse à
tous les pays à toutes les civilisations
pour développer la prime merci beaucoup
lansana camara puis bonne couverture
avoue tout de même merci plus depuis
plusieurs jours ici à montpellier se
déroule parallèlement à ce nouveau
sommet afrique-france un contre sommet à
l'initiative d'un collectif
d'associations et de militants pour
dénoncer les maux de la françafrique il
semble devient d'ailleurs que les
autorités soient sur le qui vive puisque
hier les autorités ont arrêté des
militants en faveur des sans-papiers à
leur descente du train à la gare de
montpellier à un train donc en
provenance de paris